[موسيقى]
يطلب اكثر من 11 الف صوت اضافي في ولايه
جورجيا هذا مقطع من مكالمه هاتفيه مدتها
ساعه دارت في الثاني من يناير 2021 بين
ترامب
السياسي الجمهوري الذي يشغل منصبا رفيعا
في ولايه جورجيا
هذا التسجيل هو في قلب ملف قضائي اخر قد
يجلب الرئيس السابق امام محكمه في ولايه
جورجيا الامريكيه بتهمه محاوله تغيير
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها
جو بايدن
المدعيه العامه للمقاطعه فولتن في ولايه
جورجيا فاني ويليس تعمل منذ اكثر من عامين
على التحقيق حول هذا التسجيل وما اذا كان
يشكل جريمه قد تنهي امال في الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه في عام 2004
لكن الدراما القانونيه السياسيه لن تتوقف
هنا
فالجمهوريون في هذه الولايه الصغيره بدروا
باتخاذ اجراءات ضد المدعيه العامه ونادوا
بالغاء التحقيق واقالتها لانها دعمت مرشحا
ديموقراطيا بتنظيمها لحمله تبرعات تهمت
المدعيه العامه بان التحقيق القضائي الذي
تقوده بخصوص ترامب ما هو الا حمله سياسيه
مغرضه هدفها عرقله مساعيه الانتخابيه
ثاني ويليس لم تعلن اتخاذ اي اجراءات
قانونيه تجاه ترامب حتى الان ولكن مصادر
صحفيه امريكيه تقول ان السلطات مقاطعه
فولتون تقوم بتعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه حول
مقر الادعاء العام والمحكمه وهذا قد يكون
مؤشرا على استدعاء قريب للترامب
انماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات